These are the 74 terms of government in Mexico,
between emperors,
presidents,
s,
interim and reelections.
From Agustín de Iturbide to the current President
Andrés Manuel López Obrador.
I want to talk to you
a brief summary of who has governed us,
what they did and how they are remembered.
We begin in 1821,
with Agustín de Iturbide,
emperor of the first Mexican empire.
We continue with Guadalupe Victoria,
recognized as the first President of Mexico in 1824,
derived from the first constitution of our Mexico.
We continue with Vicente Guerrero,
Insurgent Chief and President 1 829.
From here we move on to a very brief 7-day interim period.
headed by Bocanegra.
the first triumvirate arose,
that is,
a collegiate body to head the executive branch
by Luis Quintanar,
Pedro Vélez and Lucas Salamán,
followed by three mayors from 1,830 to 1,833,
to the point of controversy
President Antonio López de Santana,
who was President of Mexico on 11 occasions
different over 20 years.
He is remembered for having granted independence
to Texas in the year 1 847,
during the U.S.
intervention
and the defeat of the Mexican army,
Santana signs the treaties of Guadalupe Hidalgo,
ending the war
against the United States
and thus giving more than half of it
of our national territory.
Years later,
Antonio López de Santana
calls herself His Most Serene Highness,
signing the table treaty
and ceding another large portion of the national territory
in exchange for compensation in the year 1853.
In summary from Mil833 to Mil855,
Santana was religious 11 times,
The result was a period of anarchism and misgovernment.
In 1854,
a broke out
headed by Juan Álvarez,
a liberal,
through Ayutla's plan.
Santa Ana is unknown.
In 1855,
Juan Alvarez,
in his short two-month term of office,
issues the Juarez law
and suppresses military andal forums.
That same year,
was comfortable,
being President of the Republic,
ignores the constitution of 1857,
with Tacubaya's plan,
generating a self-coup d'état.
And that is when Benito Juarez became President.
interim and Félix María Zuluaga
as President of the coup leaders.
This is how the three-year war begins,
better known as the war of reform.
From 1,857 to 1,861,
between liberals and conservatives.
Mexican governors
convinced Napoleon,
the third of France,
to execute an imperial project in our Mexico.
Therefore,
in one thousand 862,
the termination of payment in respect of the foreign debt,
the French army invades our Mexico
and in 1864,
Napoleon the third granted his approval
to Maximilian of Habsburg
to rule the Mexican throne,
thus initiating the second Mexican empire.
In 1867,
Benito Juarez reestablishes the Republic
and was elected President.
In 1872,
when Sebastián Lerdo de Tejada
is elected President,
elevates reform laws to constitutional rank.
In one thousand 876,
Porfirio Díaz elected President of the Republic
up to 1880,
when his compadre,
one-armed Manuel González,
modify the Magna Card
and Porfirio Díaz returns and is religed until 1911.
During the dictatorship De Porfirio Díaz,
considered as the Porfiriato,
was plagued by clear events,
from rail development,
generating
the first cuts in public finances,
also the development of 19,000km of tracks,
boosting industry and infrastructure.
Despite financial and industrial achievements,
infant mortality exceeded 50 percent.
80% of the Mexican population
was illiterate and wealth was found only
in a few hands
and social inequality was extremely great.
In 1911 Francisco Madero,
considered as the prototype of democracy
and hero of the Mexican Revolution,
wins the elections
and puts an end to the dictatorship of Porfirio Díaz.
If we reach one million plays
I will upload the second part of this video.
Thank you very much